thunderhorse I had to grab a quick snack
enter and if you have been on any of the
streams or watch the latest YouTube
video you will know what that snack is
okay less than four three tournaments
start in time and position one minute er
let's see what pieces I don't get a lot
of pieces Oh who's that
Achmed is that the puppet they're all
where's the queen night the queen night
is long gone this is gonna start to make
you're gonna be seen a lot of this
you're gonna be seeing a lot of it
but I have sneaky ideas with these moves
okay coming after you
come on the Knights coming after you
here comes the a part the bishop is
close to being dead push there and let's
see if they take that it's probably good
but I don't know let's keep that guy
away Oh what am i doing 34 seconds okay
okay let's get this in oh I'm in trouble
oh I'm in big trouble save me save me
this night has to go but they're
probably just gonna recapture it the
night now they're not why don't they
just recapture the night oh man I am in
rough shape my King has to run I don't
have any time wait do I have me oh I'm
gonna lose my what lose my rook oh my
god God nothing defend rook come on rook
defend
I'll quick mate you know you want to
fall for me whoa what's the King doing
let's try a check-in take this another
check
take my rook take the Queen
run oh oh I only have two seconds this
is not a good start I don't have any
time
oh come on go quick how many how much
time oh I don't have any time back to
turn oh I got
thunderhorse ma'am negative two negative
two I'm starting with even less time
than usual cuz I had a little boost with
my rating so they they hit me even
harder when it comes up when it comes
time for the time thing okay let's close
this up uh-oh
I'll get material back though I'm
getting material back here we go let's
chop that guy up hit the Queen bring my
bishop back Oh ahead f6f-5
let's go for that now Oh Pond takes get
that out of there get out of there get
out of there get out of there I'm on the
bishop I'm on the night I'm on the night
what do they got come on both rooks I'm
on the night let's take this guy and oh
that's a free rook I'm gonna take that
definitely gonna take free pieces trade
city trade a bunch and I'm up a rook
more trades back to tournament I have
zero points
okay this is tough very very tough is
this tournament okay
actually they're doing a double fee and
keto huh this is what I'm gonna do to
react to that each pond attack age pond
here we go I'm on the night they're
gonna move that pond night here let's
get out of that and what am i doing over
here
I should be attacking their king Oh give
me that I'm going to take that pun I'll
take that pond push pin no it's not a
pin let's block that I want to save my
rook ooh what are they doing they're
giving me pieces but all they're getting
that though now they're not okay um
what's the material count what is the
material count it seems like I'm
probably down upon probably down upon
here and let's come over here and then
get b5 in could this can I make this
work somehow I can also target f4 my
rook could do more than what it's doing
right now let's play here and then do a
pawn push after they defend okay just to
get some activity here just to get some
activity there we go activity right here
no no no no no let's come over here oh
now I do this if they okay they didn't
block with their rook my king wants to
be over here now over here keep this
rook right here right here
that's not a good move is it oh it is
actually what am i doing okay I gotta go
with this and then take two pawns
oh I almost mouse slipped I didn't give
a check they probably thought I was
gonna do that
come over here free move they probably
thought I was gonna give check let's get
back here let's do this
more checks checks for everybody I'm
back here even if they check take my
rook no no yes yeah
oh they could have took my pawn okay
they probably thought I was gonna take
it okay four points cat mixer ten nine
eight seven six
no no seven okay Oh what is the Queen
rook when you need it where is that
Queen rook when you need it it's nowhere
to be found
okay so what do you do when you don't
have a queen rook what do you do when
you don't have a queen rook no traits
for you come on Knight you know you want
to move you know you want to move Knight
if rook b8 I get my Hall you're gonna
give me this file open it up come on
let's go break this open break this down
here we go crashing through boom oh this
is brutal are they gonna see it up there
hang on what am i doing
let's play here so I my Bishop can move
there we go and now oh I got the Queen
and more pieces everything's falling
let's go here I could pre move that
nothing Bad's gonna happen
let's get my knight involved hit the
pinned piece that's the name of the game
pile up on the pinch piece chop-chop me
back to tournament eighteen twelve
twelve eleven ten can I recover from a
big speed bump to start this tournament
I have my queen night around to help out
with that I will not the Queen night is
out of play I did you get my queen night
back into play that Queen night is doing
nothing okay what do you do without a
queen night let's close shop close shop
open up the G file come on give me the G
and the G file bishop okay G filed is
let's get back over here do something
over here bishop stop that Queen for
coming H for I don't want that H for
mood to come by white and then it's
locked down my light square bishop needs
to weasel about over here hit the rook
come here here I'm okay if that Knight
takes me go ahead take me okay don't
take me let's lock it down over here
okay I'm take towards the center let's
have a good reason not to guess what I
have not a good reason not to take like
that okay maybe I do because in here
incoming we got a knight right here a
pesky night let's castle and let's come
over here and look for tricks looking
for tricks Queen takes aged Queen takes
age you know you want to take there we
go we got something got something going
on Queen back to g3 and that's from IH
pun it's another H pawn attack less than
17 I got the bishop this is winning now
this is a winner
uh-oh uh-oh this is gonna be brutal H
takes G and the whole house falls I
could actually pre move that because
guess what I have made a ruski hang on
no this is close to me let's skip check
okay back to tournament 18 lost on time
twenty eight twenty nineteen eighteen
who is this no no fries no no fries no
no fries okay all right no no fries
let's do battle let's do battle Bishop
takes pawn okay get it an attack where
are they going now wherever my knight
ends up going they go somewhere else
they're being it being smart about
things here let's come over here I want
to get b5 in are they gonna lock things
up okay now let's make this happen make
it happen
my light-square bishop gonna come to
life kick that guy away place them in a
pin it's probably annoying if I do that
there we go hey things annoying here how
can you make things annoying for my
opponent let's castle rook here and then
this is the next move open this up I'm
on the bishop twice this is actually
winning now bishops dead and they have
to give up their queen or night ouch I'm
gonna keep that pin why my LightScribe
bishop to come into play then chop and
chop again with check and then the
Knights falling I'm on it with the Queen
I also have the bishop Queen takes
bishop queen takes bishop it is okay
let's chop this guy give a check check
and then main no matter where he goes
Oh time chicken anon mover oh oh it's an
odd mover it's a non mover here no no
fries not moving not moving Nona okay
non moving Nona let's go back to
tournament I had to win on time with
that one I think unless there was a
crazy glitch and that actually could
happen that um that could happen though
so let's just assume that it was
actually chess cubes fault blame chest
cube don't bleep totally Oh bad to work
that one into the vocab they pulled or
no
they pulled a Nona fry what in the world
are you talking
they pulled a note of fry on me okay
let's close that one down no no the non
mover Nonna Nonna Nonna I'm on the
bishop are they gonna take and allow my
dark-squared bishop to become a an
animal take that puck oh there goes the
dreaded um it's a dreaded it's um the
heart of the structure oh here comes the
dark square bishop it's ready to rumble
h4 g4 oh they could take that they could
take that pun do they know they can take
that pun they didn't know or maybe they
did let's take this guy I'm on the rook
I'm gonna chop it up hmm
let's go over here I'm on the night I'm
on the night they see that it's open up
this file I want my rep to play my rook
wants to play my rook would like to play
a little bit okay okay here we go
my rook is extremely active and this
night is out of play extremely active
and the knight is pinned and then not
quite when it's not a painting win it's
not as clean as that is it just can't be
clean so I got to get my King out and
about here we go
let's get my rook doing something let's
get going two pigs looking for a couple
pigs oh let's not give a check there
Bishop's don't move like that
another rook looking for me Oh Oh
looking for this get that and then
looking for me there we go making one
threat what do they got let's take that
check check again and then checkmate the
bishops controlling he won forfeit on
time back determine 56 54 40 15 minutes
we're halfway there but wow I have to
recover and this is these are the
toughest games where I don't have my
bishop pawns
I don't have any bishop pawns I need my
bishop pawns
okay let's put pressure on f7 maybe this
could be decent I want to avoid a queen
exchange Grand Prix attack like position
okay I can't take that pond because a
queen d4 check so they were being in
sneaky let's get out of that diagonal
before it's too late and maybe just
maybe I could get f4 in and pile up on
this piece come on take nope let's back
up not kicking me out for that so soon
if the knight moves I chop actually I'm
just gonna chop and now they're out of a
pin ah I shouldn't have allowed that Oh
Queen trade okay let's hit this and then
I got this move the rook moved a rough
move the rook you know you want to move
that rook
okay let's try this let's try this and
then I'm gonna end up in a fork it's
just a can't it just can't be clean can
it
there is no f5 the knight has to move
and then what I do night Oh night there
goes my beautiful Bishop the beautiful
Bishop left the scene by night looking
for f5 oh they're looking for Forks I
got a pre move free mph
mmm not so fast free move yep not so
fast pre move I'm in a pin oh wait a
second wait a second I like my tricky
Knight I'm gonna keep him around
tricky Knight tricky Knight tricky
Knight give a check come over here take
this pawn with check tricky Knight
tricky Knights attack come on King help
out we've a mate King we've a mate you
know you want to give me make it one
threat take my knight come
sneak over here just in time mine I
could block oh I can't block they're
probably gonna take my night if I did
that uh uh go over here how much time do
they have check run King check check
yeah sucked out of time I'll take it
72 54 52 double those points okay wow I
didn't mean to do this I'm forgetting
I'm out of rook here I'm forgetting him
down a rook I'm forgetting I'm down a
rope man name of the game is burn the
clock what else can you do what else can
you do but burn a clock here okay get
your clean okay Queen to h3 this is like
that last minute one that last minute
when I somehow got that one time maybe
to threat Queen takes Queen takes there
it is make it - this is very similar to
that win back to tournament I needed
that 70-74 neck and neck right here no
we're not Nick like anymore he's got 79
oh this is the leader this is the pack
leader right here this is the oh this is
the Cesar Millan of chess um pack leader
if you didn't know is Cesar Millan let's
castle castle and get out of tricky
checks why did I drop that piece why did
I drop that piece okay okay stay calm
here
stay calm you've got something good
brewing you have something good brewing
and it starts with this and it also
starts with getting the h-file attack
you know you want to make the h-file
attack work let's go in the center Forks
open up the LightSquared dog and I'll
hit the Queen all that fun stuff is
happening now all the crown in the ball
check over here it's fun over here it's
a lot more fun over here let's play here
Oh
rook takes this is an important win what
am i doing I'm floundering they're
taking out my number-one player right
there my LightSquared bishop they're
taking it out they're having none of it
they're having none of it
let's come over here hit a pond close it
up let's come back over here I think
there was Knight takes pawn there they
messed okay let's let's do this and
let's lock it up
hopefully the Queen does end up here oh
it's gonna end up there isn't it okay
can I get this check check they gotta be
a little bit scared they have to be a
little bit scared check this is working
out this is me oh this is important win
six five four three what do you got no
time yes back to tournament a clutch win
88-81 77 67 this is the thunderhorse
this is the Thunder horse right here and
I am once again without a horse and you
know what the Thunder horse okay alright
this is um pretty crazy here down on
time down on position let's get these
bishops out and about what are they
doing okay Castle kingside please Castle
kingside let's do this maybe they want
to go Queen side I'll be ready for that
okay let's lock this up Trading there
wouldn't have been good okay let's take
this and get my Knight to g4 he is gonna
love the g4 square I think oh I'm gonna
like that bishop though that bishop move
taking the night
stop castling okay they missed that one
they definitely missed that one oh
they're gonna take my knight here first
oh I get the I get the Queen temple on
the Queen though let's do this Bishop
I'm still in the bishop take the bishop
bishop here I can't castle now I can't
castle let's chop this no why did I chop
that
Oh me mate is right around the corner
for my opponent oh man this is very
scary let's open this up
Knight here is killer isn't it I gotta
open up the B file I also have to hang
on to my rook oh I can't leave I can't
leave with this rook is it gonna be mate
come on save me save me I can always
play Knight here maybe mate threat
somehow I'm on the rope they missed that
mate coming up mate
yes back to terminal 108 108 101 77 it
seems like it's just between myself and
that guy the one that's within 10 okay
alrighty
you've seen this before it's um it's
happening again let's see what they've
got are they gonna go Kings side okay
I'm coming after you coming after you
now each pond and G pond that's it that
night again
Oh Queen takes that's all right I got
Rick here let's chop that get on the
diagonal no let's get over here oh oh
okay that's alright dad is quite all
right um oh I have this I have this
right because my Queens guarding oh
they're getting scared are they getting
scared Castle queenside castle here we
go
I want to get out of this diagonal quick
oh man I'm constrained to my knight I
don't like that I want to get it out of
there hit the Queen get out of that and
then push here I got a different Oh
actually I have to do b4 if a five keep
things closed over here okay I got to
close things up a little bit I want to
open up the be for square for my Queen
timely checks oh I should have done that
right away the rooks gonna take that
pawn keep my rook on this open file
Queen back here and
then rook here is probably good somehow
me can get a mate let's try a check-in
is this mate
King move and I got me does that mean
it's me yes that's less than seven 128
121 AB AB is Jay okay no night no night
why aren't they moving why not they
moving they're not moving oh they might
have disconnected they just might have
disconnected
oh how untimely how untimely let me do
some cookin here look I'm gonna pre move
that just so they don't grab my rope if
they play Bishop g2 and this guy right
here I need to do some home prep home
cookin leaders AB where's that AB
character here he is what does he play
he's a white as white he plays d4 d5
Knight f3 e6g 3c5 okay alright so maybe
he's just a d4 player my game is not
starting Earths it's still not over yet
this guy's gonna win this one soon
he's about maybe how many seconds behind
ok I gotta close out of that one did he
just win that one we're gonna see what
the standings are after this I couldn't
see I closed out too soon 126 leaders
leaders leaders 131 oh he has a lead he
has a lead 136 126 um come on come on
come on
quick resigner even though I'm out of
horse they're not moving again Oh an odd
mover alright well I'm gonna do that is
another pre move and I'm gonna do some
more home prep here against that guy oh
now there's two of them
ah man come on come on come on come on
malice is now the leader mallas what do
you play mallas oh this is the one that
I beat and now is how is he back in it
I thought I'd knock this guy out oh man
alright well I already have experience
with this guy I think this one's gonna
propel me into the lead but then they're
gonna win their games Oh what's going on
with this 151 137 this is ah this is
brutal okay less than ten seconds less
than ten less than ten and we gotta I
need to get two more games in two more
games at least 136 you see they're not
doubling points either those aren't
double points games because they're just
not playing 151 137 I need to be paired
up with this guy
three minutes 35 seconds
okay Johnny Smith
Johnny Smith are you oh I thought it was
a third a third one in a row okay
no bishop check oh oh oh
bishop you I would add play kini two
dodged a bullet I dodged a bullet
Knight g3 oh I dodged another bullet
that could have been bad that could have
been pretty bad does that Bishop again
and all right I don't want to take that
just out I want to trap it actually I
want to trap that Bishop let's do this
they're gonna kick my night away okay
lets him
let's run King run King before it's too
late
okay I'm going to capture with my it
doesn't matter actually I was in a rough
shape if they um took right there cuz my
rook was gonna be hanging okay now I got
to get my rook out of there I'm hanging
my rook but they don't have very much
time Bishop takes rook is available
let's do this I want to get this move in
please allow me to get this move in no
they're not allowing you to do that now
the rook is very active rook is very
active and I don't know what that move
does and oh they're just giving me that
Queen trade oh oh oh is this me please
don't let it be me my rook is still
hanging by the way my rook is still
hanging if you didn't realize Queen
trade is only one it's gonna happen now
maybe or not or yes I should take away
my queen
okay back to term it 156 130 800 wait
could I sneak in another wind they're
probably gonna win Jackson how much time
do I have 138 what do I have like 20
seconds to maybe try and get this one
I'm on the bishop quick win come on how
much time do I have I have to take a
peek I have to take a peek at that let's
see if I have enough time that's a good
move I should have got castle by I had
the chance I should have done that
shouldn't I have what about this get rid
of that bishop get on this diagonal
hitting the knight yes chop this guy
next get here get here
stop that rip from getting active
actually I have to come back if they
give check-check
come on go go go go go go go I want to
keep my rook around and get these pawns
maybe mate maybe mate actually somehow
let's come over here run King
rook check I get it what do we got what
do we got are they gonna move how much
time is left 26 seconds I'm on the rook
26 seconds oh if they let their clock
tick back to tournament 176 I have a
lead
176 come on tick tick tick tick tick
tick tick hopefully nobody gets finished
we saw what happened last time 12 11 10
go for quick mate
quick make quick make quick mate mmm
come on just chop that just go here
chop chop everything clean over here
kill that hang on they might make me
finish this game that happened before
what do we got there it is whoo I will
take that the thunderhorse
alrighty the Thunder roars I did not
think I was gonna get that one because
that first round dead
I was killed I was in negative territory
land man nuts
I guess those guys didn't finish oh I
finished though all right I'm gonna take
that wind the Thunder doors I guess I
have Thunder Horse bragging rights for
two hours